und wir starten in die sendung mit einer
breaking news denn es gab eine bluttat
in dänemark zwei jugendliche und einen
mann sterben bei der attacke im
einkaufszentrum viel in kopenhagen der
täter psychisch krank er hat gestanden
ja wir sehen verwackelte handy aufnahmen
verstörte menschen der menschen in panik
paare familien kinder rennen um ihr
leben suchen in ausgang der mall wer sie
eben noch in ruhe gebummelt haben und
wir hören immer wieder schüsse
[Applaus]
schreier wurde für unseren kopenhagener
sterben drei menschen bei den opfern
handelt es sich um einen 47 jahre alten
russen der in dänemark lebte und zwei
junge dänen einen 17 jährigen jungen und
ein 17 jähriges mädchen vier weitere
menschen werden schwer verletzt darunter
auch ein erst 16 jahre alte lucia und
das soll er sein der todesschütze von
kopenhagen ein 22 jähriger däne hier
heimlich von einem besucher der mall
gefilmt der mutmassliche täter trägt
jagdbekleidung eine kurze hose eine
schwarze weste erhält eine langwaffe und
ein jagdgewehr in den händen auch hier
sind schüsse zu hören
dann plötzlich schultert er dann seine
waffe und trend hin zum ausgang der mall
hier sehen wir hier und hier wird er
dann kurz darauf von einem weiteren
handy gefilmt und jetzt kommen auch
immer mehr details zum kopenhagen killer
ans licht am tag vor seinem massaker
veröffentlichte 22 jährige diese videos
hier von sich im internet viel videos
sind mit einer gesamtdauer von fast zehn
minuten alle zeigen ihnen mit einem
gewehr oder einer pistole posiert mit
den waffen hält sich diese immer wieder
selbst in den kopf er soll psychisch
krank sein und schauen wir uns jetzt
noch einmal den ablauf genauer anderem
17 uhr 35 ging der alarm bei der polizei
ein mehrere schüsse fielen im
shoppingcenter viel ist die größte mall
dänemarks übrigens kam plötzlich ein
lauter knall im ersten stock der panik
wir sehen hier die menschen die
fliehenden todesangst über die
treppenhäuser und draußen an polizei
überall streifen waren feuerwehr und
weniger als einer viertelstunde kann der
täter an einem kreisverkehr in der nähe
des einkaufszentrums festgenommen werden
eine terrortat schließt die polizei aus
das telefonnetz das internet alles war
teilweise so überlastet dass anrufe
unmöglich waren alle verließen einfach
nur fluchtartig die viel small der
terror die angst steht allen ins gesicht
geschrieben auf diesen beiden
es ist der reine terror es ist furchtbar
man könnte sich fragen wie ein mensch
einem anderen menschen so etwas antun
kann aber es ist jenseits jenseits von
allem was möglich ist meine älteste
tochter die 18 jahre alt hält sich
gerade so über wasser eine andere
tochter wurde in dem tumult der begannen
als der täter offenbar überall schüsse
abfeuerte auch an mehreren stellen von
den menschen und den umfallenden stühlen
verletzt es ist furchtbar
wir hatten uns gerade hingesetzt und
unser essen gegessen weil wir zum harrys
teils konzert gehen wollten und dann
waren wir gerade fertig und dann kam
angerannt wir dachten vielleicht haben
sie harrys teils gesehen weil er ja
gerade in der stadt ist und wir dachten
oh das ist eine lustige sache aber dann
fingen die leute an zu rennen und wir
sagen die panik oder einen typen mit
kinderwagen in dem sein kind saß und er
fiel einfach um also nahm das kind und
rannte weg und wir dachten nur das ist
kein witz mehr und dann wurde ziemlich
ernst wir wussten nicht was wir tun
sollten also rannten wir wir rannten aus
dach und saßen dort eine weile fest
während die leute überall in panik
gerieten und weinten
reporter im caritas live vor der
shopping mall vielzahl wo sich gestern
von einer sekunde auf die andere alles
änderte hallo ibo was kannst du uns über
ein mögliches motiv und auch über den
hintergrund des täters sagen
patricia die polizei hat kurz nach
unserer schalter heute morgen hier den
tatort ein bisschen weiter freigeräumt
für uns pressevertreter damit wir halt
eben näher rankommen können und ich
würde euch zumindest vorab einmal kurz
zeigen weil er das gerade auch in der
anmoderation so beschrieben hat wie
schnell quasi das normale leben sich
verändert hat durch diese lauten knall
durch diese schüsse die man gehört hat
dafür würde ich einmal kurz mit luca
gemeinsamen rüber schränken und euch zu
zeigen anhand dieser einkaufswagen die
wir da sehen wie panisch und wie wie
dramatisch das alles gestern abgelaufen
sein muss nach dem wahrscheinlich der
erste kanal oder die ersten vier schüsse
abgegeben wurden die leute haben da
sieht man noch ein bisschen den
zugemüllten boden die leute haben ihre
sachen fallen lassen haben die
einkaufswägen stehen lassen wir haben
rechts einem bild wir haben vor uns
direkt einem bild und wenn wir nach
links schauen denn hier ist auch ein
restaurant dann sehen wir das sind noch
teilweise
volle gläser das bedeutet hier war es
gestern bei schönen wetter belebt ihr
saßen die leute hier haben sie den
sommer genossen und die dänische
ministerpräsidentin sagte das schon dass
hier leute so krass aus einem schönen
sommer rausgerissen wurden durch so eine
tat das dass die so sicher geglaubte
hauptstadt plötzlich erschüttert wurde
und nicht mehr so ist wie sie einmal war
und auch wenn wir jetzt einmal uns
komplett drehen wir müssen hier ein
bisschen bitte seht also nach mit einem
auge bei dem man sein der den täter
gestern gefilmt hat deswegen schaue ich
ein bisschen ab und zu nach links aber
jetzt ein bisschen weitergehen dann sind
wir auch schon nicht nur für
pressevertreter sind die hoch gekommen
sondern die ersten
passanten haben ihre chance genutzt um
ihre anteilnahme zu zeigen und haben
hier blumen niedergelegt so sieht es
aktuell gerade hier bei uns aus in der
nähe der shopping mall wenn wir über den
täter besprechen wollen dann wissen wir
zumindest dass er polizeibekannt war und
dass er in psychiatrischer behandlung
war wir wissen dass er geständig ist
denn er hat im laufe seiner vernehmung
heute nacht diese tat gestanden
gestanden was er da gestern gemacht hat
das bedeutet wir sprechen nicht mehr
über einen mutmasslichen täter sondern
wir sprechen hier über einen geständigen
täter und wir wissen inzwischen auch
dass es keine rassistischen oder terror
hintergründe geht wie es über social
media anfangs vermutet wurde denn dieser
mann wird sich seine opfer
höchstwahrscheinlich willkürlich
ausgesucht haben wo eine frage noch der
täter ist ja eben schwer bewaffnet in
dort in das einkaufszentrum gelaufen
werden waffen heißt man das schon
laut dänischen medien geht man davon aus
dass der mann in einem schützenverein
tätig war das bedeutet das würde
zumindest erklären wie er diesen zugriff
auf lang feuerwaffen und munition gehabt
haben kann und
ob sich das bestätigt wird sich
letztendlich im laufe des tages zeigen
denn es werden immer wieder werden jetzt
bis eben auch wieder eine
pressekonferenz vor dem krankenhaus wo
die polizei neue infos dazu gegeben hat
da ging es aber allerdings um die opfer
auf die ich jetzt gleich eingehen werde
aber ob sich das wirklich bestätigt hat
dass er in einem schützenverein war das
wird im laufe des tages zeigen
was weißt du über den zustand auch der
verletzten und was heißt man über die
opfer
wir haben insgesamt drei tote ein 47
jähriger russe der hier in der dänemark
gelebt hat und wir haben zwei
jugendliche 17 jährige die zu den
todesopfern zählen wir wissen von vier
schwerverletzten da wissen wir zum
beispiel durch diese aktuelle
pressekonferenz dass drei außer
lebensgefahr sind bei einer person die
schwebt immer noch in lebensgefahr da
ist der zustand unverändert und von die
polizei hat tatsächlich korrigiert denn
ich habe in unserer letzten schalte
gesagt dass es sich um zwei schweden und
zwei denen gehandelt hat das müssen wir
jetzt korrigieren denn es handelt sich
bei den schwerverletzten um zwei
schweden eine dänin und eine 16-jährige
die ist das jüngste opfer ist
schweizerin vielen dank für deine ganz
aktuellen informationen dort aus gucken
haben danke schön wenn wir begrüßen
jetzt die kriminalpsychologin karoline
roshdi sie arbeiten in der prävention
von amoktaten frau roche die noch wissen
wir wenig über den täter dennoch ist
auffällig in diesem video das er sich
offenbar fast schon mit einer art genuss
auch filmen lässt dann auch immer wieder
pausen in seinen angriffen macht was
sagt das über ihn aus na ja wir haben
bei diesen tätern einem jagd modus der
gewalt vorlegen also man stellt sich die
immer recht agil und wütend vor doch
fahrzeugen berichten meistens dass die
täter rechte ruhig agieren weil im
vorfeld zu einer tat eben auch ein
empathie abbau stattfindet
diese taten fall nicht aus heiterem
himmel
das ist ein weg zur gewalt in diese
personen gehen und auf diesem weg wird
eben auch empathie tötungshemmung gebaut
und dadurch wirken die recht ruhig und
dieses lächeln oder wie man es auch
benennen möchtest wirkt dann auch
manchmal sehr verstörend auf
außenstehende überrascht was raten sie
sagen welche rolle spielt für täter bei
solchen attentaten der wunsch den ruhm
zu erlangen
das ist sehr häufig spielt das eine ganz
große rolle sie schauen im vorfeld auch
informieren sich über andere täter und
taten und da spielt dann leider auch der
body count eine eine rolle also je
größer der opfer pool ist desto mehr
berühmtheit aus sicht von tätern kann
man erlangen und das ist auch oft einen
ein motiv von personen die eben in der
realität nicht so ja sozial
erfolgreich sind oder auch so viele
soziale fähigkeiten haben
und in der die antizipieren eben dann
eine gewisse berühmtheit für etwas zu
stehen
paraschiv in herzlichen dank ihnen für
diese andere leser